Hi everybody, I'm Cameron Pittman.
Welcome to this short course
on JavaScript promises.
Every web developer needs to be
able to handle asynchronous work
with confidence and ease,
and that's why you're here.
You're here to take advantage
of native JavaScript promises.
There are many methods to handle
asynchronous work already.
However, as you'll be
discovering in this course,
promises are the recommended option,
because they give you flexibility,
intuitive syntax, and
easy error handling.
But before we start all that,
I have an off topic question for you.
[SOUND] You're looking
at millions of stars in
the disk of our Milky Way galaxy.
Every dot is a star.
Some are bigger and brighter than
the sun, others smaller and dimmer.
But what else is in this picture?
Planets.
Every single star in the Milky Way
is the possible home for
dozens of alien worlds.
That means it's likely
that there are hundreds of
billions of planets in our galaxy alone.
The Kepler Space Observatory
has found more
than 1,000 exoplanets like this
one in the last few years.
Combined with data
from other telescopes,
astronomers have confirmed sightings
of almost 2,000 exoplanets.
That's a lot of worlds.
I had an idea when I was
designing this class, and
I call it the Exoplanet Explorer.
It's a web app that helps people learn
about real planets around other stars.
Throughout this class, you'll be using
promises to request real JSON data about
exoplanets, and that data is
coming from NASA and CalTech.
You'll be using promises to turn that
data into useful information in the app.
Are you ready to get started?